- Hey, out there.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
into another edition of Market Takes.
Man, it's a great day for
financial news, a great day.
I appreciate you tuning in.
I know you could have been
anywhere in the world,
but you are here with me,
right here on Market Takes.
I am Dion Rabouin, reporter
at the Wall Street Journal.
Before we dive into our usual look ahead
at what's going on this week,
we've gotta take a second step back
and talk about what's going
on with First Republic Bank,
the sale of the JP Morgan Chase.
We will be breaking all
that down, talking about
how that could affect
the markets going forward
and what to watch out for next.
But of course, as always,
not only will we be
talking about First Republic
and what happened today,
I'll be breaking down
the three biggest things
you need to watch out for this week.
Now, this week, in addition
to First Republic coming up,
we have the Fed's May meeting.
This is a huge week.
The Fed meets on May, or I'm
sorry, on May 2nd and 3rd.
We will hear from Fed Chair,
Jerome Powell on Wednesday.
We will talk through that.
We also get the jobs report on Friday.
But in addition to the jobs report,
there are two other big
reports coming out this week
about the labor market that
you'll want to tune into.
And third, we get Apple,
Berkshire Hathaway, Pepsi,
Pfizer, BP, Airbus, and many, many more.
This is the biggest earnings week thus far
for the first quarter period.
We are gonna break
down what you need to
watch and what matters.
So, we will get into all of that.
But first, let's take a second step back
and talk about First
Republic and what happens.
Now, this is the second biggest
bank failure in US history.
You're talking about a bank
that had nearly 200 billion
in deposits just about a quarter ago,
a little over a quarter ago
at the end of 2022 that has been seized.
It was seized by the FDIC,
the Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation,
and sold to JP Morgan Chase.
JPM assuming all of First
Republic's 92 billion dollars
remaining in deposits.
Also buying most of the bank's assets
including 173 billion dollars in loans,
30 billion dollars in security.
The FDIC hit, that's
the taxpayer is gonna be
$13 billion dollars
from its insurance fund.
The FDIC has insurance fund
for just these sorts of things.
JP Morgan also said it will
receive 50 billion dollars
in financing from FDIC.
This is the second largest
failure after if y'all remember
Washington Mutual back in 2008
that was the largest.
This is bigger
than Silicon Valley Bank,
bigger than Signature.
This was the Nation's 14th largest bank.
This is big news.
Interesting to note,
JP Morgan also is the bank that
took over Washington Mutual.
So, now JP Morgan is the
buyer or the company taking
over the number one and number
two largest bank failures
in the history of the US.
So, really quickly, how did we get here?
Well, listen, most recently you
guys have seen what happened
with Silicon Valley Bank, Signature Bank,
just this rush of deposits out the door
while investors found
out First Republic lost
about a hundred billion
dollars in deposits
in a March run on the bank
following its earnings reports
that just came out last week.
Now, the bank stock lost almost
50% of its value in one day.
That was just investors
saying, we have no confidence
that after this a hundred billion dollars
in deposits went out the door,
this bank can still hold up.
The bank only had taken
on about 30 billion dollars
in deposits from the Big Five.
That's US Bank, Wells Fargo, JP Morgan
which now owns the bank, Citigroup
and those guys, those big names.
But they were unable to sell
or put a deal together before
they reported earnings.
And once they reported that a
hundred-billion-dollar loss,
man, the wolves were in
the stock, was sold out.
And this was a huge, huge loss.
You had a collection
of uninsured deposits.
Now, if you've seen
the run on these banks,
what we saw and what we
have seen is just a run
on the banks from the biggest
or from the banks with the
most uninsured deposits.
Uninsured deposits are basically deposits
that are over $250,000.
The FDIC says, we're not gonna
ensure that you take the risk
if you put money in a bank
that's over that amount.
Silicon Valley Bank had 97% of
its deposits were uninsured.
Signature Bank, 90% of its deposits.
First Republic, 68%.
So, what comes next?
Well, the next largest
bank or the next bank
with the largest share of deposits,
uninsured EastWest Bank 67%,
Comerica with 64%, Western Alliance 55%,
Pack West 52, Zion's Bank
51, KeyCorp 47% are KeyBank.
So listen, all those are
are stocks to watch out for.
Keep your eye.
I wanna put something up here
on your screen really quickly
to just kind of show you
the overall reaction.
Now, what you're looking
at right now is the year
to date performance of
the KBW Nasdaq Bank Index.
Now, this is all the
banks an ETF that follows
all the big banks.
It's Washington Mutual, it's
JP Morgan, it's Citibank,
but it's also some of
those regional banks.
And over the course of the year,
you've seen just a huge downturn,
but over the last couple weeks,
you've seen a little bit of a pickup.
But let me throw you today,
and what we're looking
at right now, you're seeing
a little bit of turmoil.
Now, First Republic
shares have been halted.
First Republic is no longer trading
after the seizure and sale to JP Morgan.
So, it's not hurting the
overall movement of this index,
but we are seeing
overall down the index is
just a little bit negative for the day,
but it's picking back up.
We're seeing maybe some bullish
as maybe people thinking, okay,
the worries about the
overall banking sector
under our overblown and you
know, let's not overdo it.
So, that just illustrating
right now the mood on the banks,
you're not seeing a major
sell off right now in terms
of the overall banking index,
but obviously those bank shares
a little bit negative on the day.
Listen, what comes next?
Will all first republic
bank branches become
Chase Bank branches?
Like I said, Chase has
taken on those depositors.
So, if you are a first
republic bank customer,
you now bank with Chase
whether you wanted to or not.
And investors not really excited
about the banking sector,
but we're not seeing a
major sell off like we did
after SVB and Signature in
some of those collapses.
A lot of this priced in, and like I said,
First Republic has been
halted for trading.
Uninsured deposits right now becoming
a little bit less of the story.
What's becoming a bit more
of the story is what's
on your balance sheet.
What are you invested in?
A lot of these banks hadn't
invested in risky assets.
It wasn't like First Republic
or even Silicon Valley Bank was invested
in a lot of, you know,
credit derivative, swaps
and things like that,
weren't invested in crypto
and things like that.
These were a lot of treasuries,
mortgage-backed securities.
What happened was they
had taken huge losses
because the Federal
Reserve had raised rates by
at really the fastest pace
in history when you judge
by how low rates were and
how high they are now.
This is the fastest rate hiking cycle
in history for the Fed.
And that cuts into the
value of those bonds.
And so, safe things like
mortgage-backed securities
and treasuries become unsafe
because you lose value.
And a lot of these banks
weren't writing that value down.
And so, as they had to take
on more cash to hold up and pay for that
and give money back to their
customers, because again,
all those deposits are owned by the bank.
They're owned by their
customers, their liabilities,
meaning that the bank
has to give them back
if customers want them.
And customers were coming saying,
hey, give me my money back.
That means the bank had to come up
with the money for those
losses they'd suffered
in the market from the treasuries
and mortgage back
securities, things like that.
But now we're shifting into
a new phase where I think
there's gonna be more worry about,
hey, what do you own?
Are you invested in any risky stuff?
Are you hedging?
Are you properly covering your risk?
Because that was what wasn't happening
at Silicon Valley Bank.
And I think the fact that First
Republic did not have a plan
in place before they
reported an earnings loss
of a hundred billion in deposits,
well, that suggests that
maybe they weren't doing
their due diligence as bankers as well.
And that I think is gonna be
the question for investors.
Are you doing your due diligence?
Are you insuring your deposits?
Are you doing and taking
the steps necessary
so you don't suffer a bunch of big losses?
That I think segues us perfectly
into what you need to be watching
for the rest of this week
because we have a fed
meeting, ladies and gentlemen,
coming up later this week.
The FOMC is meeting on Tuesday
and Wednesday of this week.
That's tomorrow and the day after,
we will hear from Fed Chair
Jerome Powell on Wednesday.
Fed widely expected to raise
rates by 25 basis points.
That's basically priced in a hike
for May is almost completely
priced in for the market.
What we don't know is what the
Federal Reserve is gonna say
at that meeting.
What's Fed Chair Jerome
Powell going to tell us,
what's he gonna say at
the press conference
and what's that statement that they put
out at 2:00 PM Eastern time on Wednesday
going to say about how the
Fed is viewing the market,
how they view this latest failure
and collapse of First Republic in light
of the overall banking sector
in terms of banks taking
on more borrowing from
the Fed and all of that.
So, I wanna put something up here
on your screen next, right here.
And just so we can talk
about what's happening in the markets.
Now, as we look out at the markets,
this is the US treasury yield curve
and that shows us how much
bonds are yielding right now.
As you see on the left
side of your screen there,
that's one month to six month to one year.
Now a treasury yield curve is supposed
to look basically the opposite of this.
It's kind of, it's generally
either a straight line
or something like a Nike swoosh
where if you're loan
in the government money
because that's what
these treasury bonds are,
they're loans to the government.
Well, if think about
loaning someone money,
if I tell you I'm gonna pay you
back this a hundred dollars,
you loaned me in a month, you'd
say, okay, well, you know,
maybe gimme a dollar,
maybe gimme $2 just to
make up for my time.
But if I say, okay, well, I'm gonna get
this a hundred dollars from you,
I'm gonna pay you back in 30 years.
Or you're probably like,
whoa, whoa, whoa, 30 years.
I don't know what's
gonna happen in 30 years.
You gotta make it worth my while.
You're gonna have to pay me 5, 10 bucks.
You know, for that.
That's usually what happens.
So, as the further you
get out on the curve,
the higher interest payments usually are.
The opposite is happening right now
because there's fear in the markets
and there's the expectations
that the Federal Reserve is
going to keep raising rates.
And so, you see 1 month,
2 months, 3, 4, 6 months,
all around that 5% level going
from two months to about six months
and then one year you
start to get lower down.
That's because there's
worry about recession.
There's worry.
Oh, maybe these things won't get paid.
But there's also worry
that the Federal Reserve is
going to start cutting rates.
They're gonna keep rates
high in the interim,
in the short term, and then start cutting.
And that's a lot of what you're
seeing in that yield curve.
So, that what you're seeing right there
that chart illustrating expectations
for what the Federal
Reserve is going to do next.
Folks expect that they'll keep rates high
for a little while, maybe
a month, maybe two month
and then start cutting them down.
And that we're likely
headed into a recession,
which is going to force the Fed
to lower rates significantly.
And that's why you're seeing
those lower rates longer term.
So, what the Fed does
at its next meaning is
all the way priced in.
We have also seen a significant loosening
of financial conditions,
meaning stock prices higher.
The S&P is of about 8.6% year to date.
The Nasdaq of about 16% year to date
and it hit its highest in
September of 2022, just last week.
You're also seeing bond
yields down as you saw
that 10-year yield, which
is the most traded treasury
really one of the lowest,
there is in terms of
what you're getting paid
for holding that.
And we will see how that continues
because that loosens financial conditions,
makes it cheaper to borrow money,
makes companies more able to go out
and issue stock at higher prices.
Those things make it able for,
make it so that companies are
able to participate in financial markets
and get money, and the Fed
wants to slow all that down.
That's at least their goal.
So, that meeting coming
up on May, or sorry,
coming up on Wednesday,
you're gonna wanna watch that.
Now next, the jobs report
is coming out this Friday,
but before we get the jobs report,
we will get some very interesting data
on the jobs and the labor market.
We will hear from, and I
guess we're gonna hear from,
we're gonna get reports
on the jolts report,
the job opening and labor turnover survey
and we will get the
challenger job cut report
both coming out this week.
Now I want to put a chart up here
on your screen that shows you
the latest of what we've seen
in terms of the jolts number,
and here's what the Federal
Reserve has been watching.
Fed Chair Jerome Powell has
been pounding the table saying
that the labor market is out of whack.
What you see there is there
are about two job openings
for every unemployed person.
There's about 10 million job openings
a little less than that
and there's only about 6
million unemployed people.
So, what you have is
a sort is a disconnect
between folks looking for jobs
and folks looking for employees.
There's a lot more people looking
for employees and there are
people looking for jobs.
That means you have to pay more means
inflation keeps pushing higher
because wages can keep pushing higher.
When employees know that there's a lot
of job openings and not a lot of demand
in terms of a lot of people
looking for those jobs, well,
they can say, hey listen,
you wanna hire me?
I'm gonna take an extra 20% more
than what I'm making at my current job.
And I'm gonna need a big
bonus and things like that.
And these companies
because they know they're
having to compete,
they're having to pay that.
So, this charge is illustrating the kind
of out of whack state of the labor market.
The Fed has pointed to that.
They haven't really talked
about corporate earnings
which are at record highs right now
or have been at record highs
over the past few quarters.
They've pointed to the labor
market and they've said,
we need to see this come back into check
before we're gonna be
able to stop raising rates
or start cutting rates.
Now the other side of this coin,
the other side of the labor
market is another chart
I want to put up here on your screen,
and that is the challenger
job cuts report.
And that's showing
that layoffs are starting to pick back up.
We are seeing over the course
of the first three months
of this year, January, February,
March over three, or sorry,
over 400% increase from
March of the previous year.
Now that's still these low,
these layoff levels are still
at a low level historically,
but compared to where they have been,
we are seeing a significant
pickup ever since November
of last year, or I guess since November.
This chart is illustrating
how that number is picked
up and how layoffs have started to grow
and you're gonna wanna watch
that report out this week.
Last but not least, earnings reports.
Listen, we get the biggest US company
out this week reporting earnings, Apple.
That is always a barometer for
the health of the consumer.
How much are people going out
and spending on those
high-priced Apple products?
That definitely gives
you something to keep
in mind in terms of how
well the economy's going.
Berkshire Hathaway, they own
a lot of companies like Apple.
How have they been doing?
How has their portfolio looked?
You'll wanna watch out.
Warren Buffett, he's
always got something to say
and we'll hear from
that company this week.
Bud Light's parent ABInBev,
they're gonna be coming out
with earnings this week.
There's been a lot of talk
about Bud Light's partnership
or its highlighting or spotlighting
of its partnership or an
agreement with a trans influencer.
Did that really hurt the bottom line?
Well, we're gonna see, you
know, men lie, women lie.
Money never lies.
Numbers never lie I should say.
Money sometimes that we'll see,
but numbers never lie.
And we will get the numbers
on ABInBev this week.
Gas company, Shell, ConocoPhillips, BP,
those are all gonna talk
about the consumer demand for energy.
There's been a lot of questions
about that and that'll give us an impact
on how much are people driving.
But when you're driving,
you're also delivering.
How much of those earnings move this week,
we will find out all about all those.
Airbus, that's another US company always.
I'm sorry, another company
always well trafficked
and highly watched
because of what that says
about the demand for air travel.
US companies buy a lot of Airbus planes
and that's gonna tell us how confident
these airlines are looking forward
and moving forward.
Also, big tech favorites,
AMD and Qualcomm also report this week.
You were gonna wanna watch those
and that's gonna do it for
this week on Market Takes.
I know you could have been
anywhere in the world,
but you're here with me
and I appreciate that.
I am Dion Rabouin, reporter
at the Wall Street Journal.
We will catch you on Market Takes
on Wednesday at the FOMC meeting,
4:00 PM be there or be a, that's a square.
Don't do it. That's gonna do it for us.
We'll see you on
Wednesday, 4:00 PM Eastern,
right here on the next Market Takes.